hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and i'm pretty sure i don't need to tell
anyone who is listening to this podcast
that there's a difference between the
world of our everyday senses the world
we see around us and the
picture of that world that we construct
mentally with tables and chairs and
people and stuff like that
and the world as it really is and this
distinction between the world that we
immediately see
and the world as it is comes in a number
of different flavors you know we could
talk about quantum mechanics and we
could talk about the fact that
the real world in some sense as far as
we know it right now
should be thought of as a quantum wave
function of a set of fields in
space-time rather than
a bunch of objects with you know masses
and positions
located in the universe but there's
another sense there's sort of a more
down-to-earth sense in that you know we
just don't see
or sense i should say everything that is
around us
in the most obvious way we don't see the
entire electromagnetic spectrum right we
see visible light we don't see radio
waves or x-rays or whatever
we don't see neutrinos or gravitational
waves or all the dark matter particles
that are passing through us
there's a very direct sense in which we
don't see all of the world
and there's another kind of deeper sense
which is that
we tend to pay attention to certain
aspects of the world right
to things that happen on more or less
human scales
so we know that you know there's
microorganisms inside our body and
whatever and we know there are
events that only happen once every
million years or something like that but
those don't really impinge upon our
everyday awareness
and to some extent science helps us
overcome these limitations right we can
look at very tiny things very big things
we can think about very short time
scales and very long time scales
so today's guest zyatong who is very
well known in canada
she's the co-host of daily planet which
is a science program on
discovery canada and she's also a
producer host
writer director for a number of
different science shows a couple years
ago she wrote a book called the reality
bubble
and it's about this about this fact that
we sort of created a version of reality
from the data that we immediately get
and there's a whole bunch of data that
we
filter out but the reason why i thought
it was worth having a mindscape episode
about this was because
zaya goes beyond this idea that we don't
have immediate
sensory access to everything that's
going on in the world
to draw sort of philosophical and even
social moral economic political lessons
about this it's not just that we don't
see microorganisms
we also don't see the power structures
around us we don't see the invisible
features of our lives that we take for
granted we don't see
our food being produced we don't see
where the plastic goes that we throw
away
we don't see the rules that we choose to
live by or if we know that they exist we
take them for granted
so she develops this idea of the reality
bubble of we filter out
much of the data that exists out there
and only accept some of it
to go beyond just the physical and the
biological to
deeper questions about the social world
in which we live and whether we should
right what what should we be thinking
about what are the things we should be
aware of that were not necessarily
so whatever your take on what we should
do about these things i'm of the opinion
that
we should know about them right even if
you
kind of don't want to do anything about
this
factory farm or this power structure out
there you should know that it exists
right and that's why i thought this was
a good conversation to have
there's a tremendous amount of food for
thought that we have here it's a very
ambitious program
that she's talking about and i think
you'll enjoy thinking about it there's a
lot to chew on so
let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast a joy
to be on the mindscape podcast on
it is and i'm glad you finally recognize
it uh you know
so many people have to be cajoled into
thinking that uh no we're glad to have
you here and
we're going to talk about uh your book
the reality bubble so
i do actually want to do more um
uh i don't know throat clearing or or
scene setting
than usual because there's a lot going
on in this book so why don't we start
with you telling us what you mean
by the phrase the reality bubble sure i
mean i think that many of us are
familiar with bubbles of different sorts
whether we're talking about uh
real estate bubbles or tech bubbles and
usually
when you're in a bubble you're sort of
living in a distorted reality you're
with a group of people who have an idea
of
reality and it's sort of a fiction and
there's a much bigger picture reality
out there and if you're
basically if you're not paying attention
to that reality it can sometimes
crash its way in so bubbles tend to be
quite dangerous and what i'm actually
suggesting in this book
is that our entire sort of um
sort of idea of reality beyond what the
the human being is able to perceive with
our five senses
that scientists have um been able to
detect a different reality that we're
not exactly privy to
and because we're not privy to it we're
actually in quite a dangerous position
right and so is it is it fair to think
of it as an update of
plato in his cave that metaphor i think
that you know obviously
people like plato and uh you know
different people through the ages the
notion of
maya and the notion of illusions this
has been something that has been with us
for millennia for sure
um and this is perhaps an updated
version simply because with science we
actually have these tools that we can
detect this reality with so it's
not so much um philosophical
it's something a little bit more factual
so when i got into reality i didn't want
to get into
you know whether reality exists or not i
wanted to look
at uh realities that we could actually
prove
existed and you know that was one of the
things that i came across working as a
science broadcaster i think now for
about 17 years
not to date myself too much but you know
every day on the show that i worked on
daily planet we had
different scientists so you know one day
or even one part of the show there would
be a
soil scientist and then the next part
you'd have a rocket scientist and
what i realized is they were seeing
fundamentally
different um bigger picture realities or
sometimes
micro realities that existed in my own
world landscape that i was not able to
perceive
and so when naomi klein called this book
a sort of kaleidoscopic look at reality
it's because
it was it's almost like sometimes i
picture the dragonflies eye
you know with that compound lens of you
know 28
000 lenses on it and speaking to so many
different scientists it was really
exciting because i could see that they
all had this
really different vision of the world
that they could prove
existed and that was the exciting part
but
on the flip side what sort of really um
sort of the engine of the idea for the
book uh took place
uh in the shower it was one of those
showers lots of places they'll have
those shower thoughts that they post on
reddit all the time
and the book uh talks about this idea
which is in the 21st century
there are cameras everywhere except
where our food comes from
where our energy comes from and where
our waste goes
so that really struck me because we're
the most powerful species on earth
and yet we're fundamentally quite blind
to how we survive so how is it that we
have
this incredible ability to see you know
outer space
under water through walls all these
different
uh visual capabilities and yet when it
comes to some of the fundamentals
um we actually can't see very clearly at
all
and and you've seen i'm sure that meme
on the internet where they say you know
at the beginning of every horror
disaster movie there's a scientist who's
you know heralding a warning and as i
looked through these lenses
i started seeing those warnings and i
wanted to put those warnings together
in a book right so i wanted i wanted to
get that in your words because
you know given uh the description of the
reality bubble as you initially
described it i think
there are a couple of places that
listeners of this podcast might
immediately go which is sort of not the
right places to go so i wanted to let it
be very clear like one place is the idea
that
the world that we see around us looks
classical or you know ordinary even
pre-classical
manifest image folk science look there
are tables and chairs but
there's also a deeper underlying reality
which is
quantum mechanics and wave functions and
quantum fields and that is
not really what you're focusing on in
this book
certainly not um not because that's not
my area of expertise i mean that's
something that i would love to hear from
you like how you see a table
or a chair do you see it as sort of like
this fizz of particles
i mean of course this is one area that
we can't necessarily see
although we can detect so while i do
address those sorts of things that's not
particularly
uh the realm in which i go that's right
and which is fine which is perfect and
you know maybe i'll be on your podcast
someday and we can talk about
the underlying wave but then there's the
other
use of the word bubble that has been uh
you mentioned you know um
housing bubbles in stock market bubbles
but recently in
recent years the idea of a filter bubble
and an online sort of
news and information bubble that
individuals can be in
uh has become very prevalent and that's
related to what you're talking about but
it's also not exactly
the same thing you're being a little bit
more scientific here
yeah exactly because i mean i think that
we are aware that there are political
bubbles
and um you know that is a bubble in a
sense that you've got a certain select
group of people with an
insular form of thinking yeah um but in
contrast you have
other political bubbles that are more
you know differences of opinion or
differences of morality or differences
of value
whereas what i'm talking about is a
bubble where your
you know your perceptual faculties tell
you one thing
and then scientific tools and technology
can
basically envision a very different
reality and when there's a mismatch
that's when you have something that's
quite
quite dangerous that's right and i do
want to um
you know i i feel bad about doing this
but in some sense i want to give away
the punch line
right away because you know people don't
always listen to the podcast you know
what the punch line of my own book is
well i look forward so
let me let me run by you what i think a
punchline is and then you can
you can fix it uh you know given the
description that you gave of the reality
bubble
in fact given all of the text on the
back cover of your book
uh the subject in the book could easily
have just
been a list of anecdotes and factoids
about
cool things that science has taught us
about the world that our immediate
senses don't have access to
and you have a little bit of that but
then you have a much uh
i want to say deeper message or more
profound message about
not just the uh physics and biology of
our ways of sensing the world
but then you get into political social
moral economic impacts of this you know
not just
we don't see ultraviolet light but we
don't see the invisible power structures
around us and you know i think that's
uh i'm not it's not really a bait and
switch you're not being dishonest about
it but i i
liked the fact that you know you really
tried to
see a bigger picture than just some
science stories
oh well i'm so grateful that that's the
punchline you got out of it because then
i think i did my job properly
um yeah i mean i think what i found
missing you know they say often try to
write a book that you haven't seen on
the bookshelves
is one that actually does bridge uh
politics with science
so political science um you know quite
often we know that
scientists are you know creating and and
you know documenting more of an
objective reality so we don't tend to
look for the politics there
but of course that's quite necessary in
this day and age when we look at things
like
climate change and my book isn't exactly
all about climate change as you know
it's about
a whole a whole other spectrum of things
but i think that it's really important
uh to be able to bridge that gap and
that's one of the reasons why
the book really focuses on rebel
scientists you know
chapter one is looking at uh van
leeuwenhoek
and it is looking at galileo and looking
at how
you know these two fathers these big
fathers of science and microscop
microscopy today um were really mocked
and derided and considered charlatans
van davenhook certainly was because he
was seeing these invisible
animal kills that you know in the 16th
century basically didn't exist everybody
thought he was a little bit
mad um and the same thing with the
church really wanting to silence
uh galileo so there there is always a
political component to when you're
trying to challenge the status quo
so that was definitely a component that
i wanted to add and
you know my my good friend astra
taylor's been a guest on your show and
we're friends because we do have a
strong interest in um
in the political arena so that that is
definitely a part of the book that uh
i'm glad came forward for you
i always have to you know
think carefully about the the discourse
around
uh rebel scientists and this would take
i don't want to get too much into it but
i will give you a chance to respond it
would be a whole podcast in itself but
you know
like you say people like uh galileo and
van lievenhook were
were derided as charlatans but you know
most
people who are derided as charlatans are
charlatans
so exactly there are people and that's
exactly what snake oil was all about
yeah
yeah exactly people who want to take it
as a badge of honor that they're derided
as charlatans i must be doing something
right because so many people disagree
with me
uh i don't think that quite logically
follows so we have to be careful
about um the the valorization of of
rebels you i mean the the successful
rebels like galileo are absolutely
crucial but
it's hard being a rebel yeah
but i mean when you're when you're
actually creating something that is
uh again documenting i mean i suppose or
exposing
um something that's paradigm shifting
yeah then you're going up against the
status quo and
and by that very nature you are uh
rebellious not because you're choosing
to be rebellious or provocative in any
sense i mean
you know galileo was just basically
saying hey i'm seeing these mountains
and these valleys on the moon and we
thought it was a smooth orb and by the
way it isn't
right and that we might not be the
center of the universe but that's of
course
you know as many of your listeners will
well know
something that that the church
absolutely could not
um could not allow people to believe
so there was a sort of forced blindness
on the population
because that would challenge the word of
god but of course as you know that's
just the very very beginning of the book
yeah exactly and honestly you know it's
right on target for the podcast because
if
if i think back to you know over 130
episodes ago
the very introduction i did to the idea
of mindscape was
if there's one theme i want to sort of
tease out it's that
not just the importance of being
rational and thinking about the world
but the importance of choosing which
things to think about
in the world right paying attention to
some things and not paying attention to
others
can be just as important for the
conclusions we land on
as the reasoning process we use once we
pay attention to those things
yeah absolutely
podcasts are small businesses i'll
confess the mindscape podcast is
sufficiently small that there are no
employees other than me
but if i wanted to hire someone i would
go to indeed.com
indeed is the hiring site that helps you
find quality candidates
with indeed instant match indeed
searches through the millions of resumes
in their database to help show you
great candidates instantly so you can do
the part you really need
faster meeting and hiring great people
unlike some sites indeed gives you full
control and payment flexibility
delivering a quality short list right
away with indeed
there are no long-term contracts you can
pause your account at any time and you
only pay for what you need with instant
match you see a list of great candidates
with 08
and indeed delivers 4 times more hires
than all other job sites combined
if you want your quality shortlist fast
you need indeed
right now our listeners get a free 75
credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
mindscape this is indeed's best offer
available anywhere
a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape offers valid through march 31
terms and conditions apply
and the final thing final bit of throat
clearing before we get into the
substance of your book i apologize for
this but
you know one of the features of your
book which i'm sure is entirely
intentional
is that you say things that make people
feel uncomfortable
right the people are going to i do yeah
okay yes people are just going to say i
don't want to hear that
and you know hearing certain things
about the world
might naively imply some
moral or political conclusions and i
think that's why people
will feel uncomfortable about it or
might seem to imply them anyway
but i think we can all agree i'm going
to propose that we can all agree let me
know if you agree
that we should all be able to face the
facts right like regardless of what
conclusions you draw about
how to think about the world and what is
right and what is wrong
we can't hide from our view
those facts which make us feel a little
uncomfortable yes
and so as you know from reading the book
it's divided into three
main sort of uh sections and the first
section really looks at those biological
blind spots that we have these are the
things that we can't see
because of our senses but the second
section of the book really looks a
little bit more at our willful blind
spots
right and these are some things that
we're unable to see and sometimes that
we deliberately don't want to see
and then the third section of the book
is more civilizational blind spots so
this looks at
some of the things that we don't see
from an intergenerational lens that
we've inherited
so that we've normalized such that we no
longer see them so there's different
ways of not being able to see different
forms of blind spots throughout the book
so don't you dare act surprised if i say
that some of the things you say make
people uncomfortable it's clear that
this is
part of the plan all along yeah and um
you know especially as a writer you have
to think about some of those things
because
you know if you're writing about things
that are going to make people
uncomfortable
that when you're when you're sitting
with a book it's very easy to just
close the book right you know you might
not want to read further
if it's something that disturbs you but
at the same time you have to structure
a book as an author such that you can
keep people interested and keep them
going throughout so
uh that was some some strategic thinking
that went into the writing process this
is why professors are often not good at
writing
trade books because they're used to
having a captive audience who gets a
grade at the end of the course
and they can start with the most boring
parts uh but okay anyway good
throat clearing done i'm glad that we're
you know the landscape is a little bit
clearer
and now we can do some science let's
start with uh
some of the sort of scientific aspects
of the story you're telling i mean
you you talk about let's just go the
literal
most literal interpretation of what
you're talking about what are the ways
in which there are
literally things going on all around us
that we don't
see or sense personally and directly
okay so i mean you know even when i'm
sitting here
right now speaking with you it would
seem
that i'm alone in a room but you know
once you start getting
you know a micro lens on the world i
start to realize that of course there's
trillions of beings that surround me i'm
in a very very busy
uh busy office space right now and even
surrounded by creatures
um that are crawling on on my face for
example so one of the things that i talk
about are the demodex mites that
uh you know are on almost all adults by
the time we reach uh adult age they're
arachnids so they're sort of relatives
of spiders
and um you know one of the strange
things about them of course is while
they have
mouths they can eat the sebum or or
other detritus on your face
they don't have anuses and so when they
crawl about on your face
every night um you know they kind of you
know eventually when they
when they pass they do sort of explode
um
their internal guts uh all over your
face
and then inside of their guts are even
smaller creatures which are
you know bacteria uh van leeuwenhoek
being the very first person
to ever spot them with his microscope so
of course there's a there's a huge
living buzzing vibrant reality
um with billions and billions of
creatures that i'm simply
unable to see and of course on the other
side perhaps on the macro
end of it and there are so many more
spectrum wise but you know
i think many of us were aware when the
when when scientists were able to image
the black hole
uh not too long ago and to be able to
see something like that
something so massive you know it's it's
so much larger and so has such a greater
mass than our very own sun
and yet it was completely invisible to
the naked eye so there are many many
things that surround us that are
invisible to the naked eye i mean
forensics
workers for another are very well aware
i was actually just watching the
the documentary the dissident the other
day
and this is the one about jamal
khashoggi
and in istanbul of course the the police
officers went in
and what looked like a perfectly clean
room once they sprayed
luminol on the room which detects uh the
iron in the hemoglobin
you start seeing the blue light you
start seeing the blood splatters all
around this room and it
it starts to reveal this really grisly
crime scene this murder scene
that you wouldn't see at all with the
naked eye so there are so many examples
that pepper the book of ways
in which we're able to see and
i think one of the ones that that struck
me
quite a bit is a story about um
a surfer whose name is mike sturdivant
and he's a surfer in florida and
he you know loved going surfing loved
going to the beach all the time
and then suddenly he he started getting
you know
sick he started getting people on the
beach around him as well
started getting lesions and um
you know sores and just feeling very
very unwell
but there seemed no reason for this
because everything looked just fine
you know nothing nothing externally had
changed
and he used to go out at night on his
boat
and he had a uv lamp that he would use
to look for petrol leaks on the back of
his boat um
so he decided to take that lamp out one
night and
uh he shot it on the beach and when he
did he was shocked and i was shocked
when i saw the images because there are
images online
um the beach was glowing this orange
color
and what was the cause of that you know
he had
absolutely no idea so he actually does
does have a geologist friend
and the two of them together started
taking samples they took something like
70 samples to science labs
to try to figure out what this this
bizarre glowing orange material was on
the beach
and that's when they discovered that it
was actually correct dispersant so
200 miles away of course there was the
bp oil spill
and during the bp oil spill the desire
was to use
dispersant not so much to get rid of the
oil but to disperse the oil
and in dispersing the oil what they were
doing was they were invisibilizing
the oil but here was a man who was
finally able to see it
and you know a beach is considered clean
if one percent of one meter of it does
not
have any oil deposits on it but of
course if you look at it with a
different light
quite literally then you can see that
there's a much more dangerous reality
that is uh just beneath the surface yeah
i i don't want to let go of
the might story actually because
it is it is emblematic of of what's
going on here because
um part of the message that you have
that we'll get into more
is sort of not just that we see you know
visible light
and not ultraviolet or infrared that's
part of it but also we see on certain
scales
of time and space and i think that if
you tell the story of
the mites living on your face to someone
uh their instant reaction would be well
surely i would notice that if there was
there are all these mites on my face but
the only reason you don't i presume
is because they're very tiny yes yes
exactly
do we how tiny are they how tiny are you
know um i don't know the exact size
of one of the dimmer decks mites but i
mean i've looked at them online
and uh they're tiny enough that they can
very snugly fit into the roots of your
eyelashes
so okay they're not so tiny that you
need a scanning electron microscope
to be able to see them um they're yeah
so they're
they're tiny but you know i mean they
can they can crawl something like 17
i think it was something like 17
millimeter meters across your face an
hour
so if that kind of gives you a size of
a sense of how small they would be to
have to make that sort of journey across
your face but
definitely they're small enough that you
know um you can't feel their
little tiny arachnid footprints walking
across your
face uh in the evening are they hiding
in nooks and crannies are they just all
over the place
on your face um they're actually mostly
in your eyelashes but they come to hunt
at night and mate at night well not hunt
actually they're basically coming to
feed at night
and so that's when they make that sort
of uh that journey
and and for me you know again just going
back into that place of writing
when you because the first chapter is
about scale as you know there's
different chapters that look at things
from different angles but
i couldn't help but constantly feel like
i was in that microscopic reality i was
picturing you know when i would picture
my nose i no longer pictured it just as
this
sort of thing on my face but more like
an everest for
you know what i mean like a huge
obstacle a nightly obstacle that these
little creatures have to to get across
in order to mate with each other from
one eye to the other so
it's fun because once you start playing
with scale of course you just start
thinking very very differently and you
know you look at grass
very differently you look at the world
of insects very very differently and
um i had i had the pleasure of meeting
an entomologist in england named tim
cockerell who is um
one of the you know one of the last a
man who
a wants to revive the flea circus but b
you know as a wonderful thoughtful
entomologist and
we sat down and we had a beer together
and uh
you know the book does start off with
this quote that he says which is you
know
quite often you'll just be sitting you
know at a at a pub
having a beer and and a little speck of
something will
fall into your beer and you'll just pick
it up and flick it away like it's
soot or like it's nothing but that's
actual animal diversity
and if you had the right lens and you
could look you know he's
he actually found a species i believe a
brand new species
previously unknown to science in a cup
of tea
so there's a just a i mean i think and i
hope the sense that you got from the
book is that
there's there's a real sense of
enchantment and awe
and wonder alongside the horror that
comes with science when you start
looking deeply
well i did want to ask about this be and
i'm sure this is going to show up again
later in the conversation but one of the
things that happens when you tell
a story like the mites or whatever
there's a million different versions of
this story because we're not very aware
of what's going on on very tiny scales
uh you do feel a little horrified a
little disgusted at this concept but
it's kind of an inappropriate response
right because
you're not saying in this case unlike
the beach story you're not saying
something has gone terribly wrong and
it's invisible to us you're saying
something is completely natural and
actually there might even be some
symbiosis where the mites are helpful to
us
i'm not sure about that but it's not
wrong you know the mites are going to be
there and you feel disgust because
you're not used to it but in fact
it's just part of what it means to be a
big macroscopic organism
yeah and i think that um i do write
about people who call themselves
disgustologists in the book right
because and that's a little bit later
when we start talking about some of the
horrors of how we treat our fellow
species but
there's a lot that we don't want to know
and and with good reason you know if
if we think that um said species or
you know it carries disease or and and
that comes up quite often with insects
or if we see
things like lesions or or death these
are all the things that
putrefaction all these things are we've
traditionally really tucked away and
tried to keep away from
our society and ourselves and there's
been a sort of
an evolutionary biological mechanism
that makes good sense for wanting to do
that
things that disgust us traditionally
haven't been
really great for us right not healthy
yeah
but but you're right in terms of the
mites this uh this is not something that
uh is harmful
it's just more harmful when you scale up
the animal and you can see
what it looks like on a larger scale and
another
scale of which that happens is the
microbiome right where
uh i think that the numbers are not
quite pinned down but at least there's a
reasonable estimate that
many more of the living cells in a human
body are
bacteria in our gut than human cells
right
we're sort of a delivery mechanism for
bacteria more than anything else
yeah i think the number now i mean you
know if you see a meme it'll say that
we're outnumbered ten to one but i think
it's one point three to one so we are
outnumbered 1.3 to one we're
slightly more bacteria than we are
human um but yeah there's it's
incredible because
of course when we're born we're born
pretty much bacteria free so we pick up
a lot of hitchhikers
uh through this journey of life well and
it goes to one of the other
uh points you emphasize in the book
which is that
the notion of a clear dividing line
between the self and the rest of the
world is fuzzier
than we conceptualize it to be you know
we human beings are open systems that
are constantly interacting with the
world around us
and what to call us and what to call the
other
is not always perfectly clear yeah yeah
and
uh that's you know that's the
chapter that is quite tricky in a sense
right because
it is really the chapter of the illusion
of the fact that we don't see the
interconnectedness of all things so
i had some fun there in terms of looking
for examples and
and ways to illustrate how porous we are
and one of the one of the things that i
became
really quite fascinated of course by is
neutrinos
because you know tiny tiny little
point-sized particles and a hundred
trillion of them are just flying through
our bodies at this very moment and
we are kind of ghost-like figures you
know in a sense that we're so porous
and so i was really quite interested in
in looking at that notion of porosity
and
and how we are made up of uh all these
sort of atomic elements that are
basically
like molecular lego that are constantly
interchanging and exchanging with the
outside world
and rebuilding our bodies and rebuilding
the universe
and and of course you would know uh that
you know so much of our bodies are made
up
of of hydrogen from the big bang in fact
you know so it's it's really incredible
how ancient we are
as beings as well as um as how new we
are as
as as condensed beings let's put it that
way well and there's an interesting
philosophy question to get into i'm not
sure how much you did because it's not
really the subject of your book but
the very idea of taking a world that
let's simplify it as a world that is
made up of
particles right protons and neutrons and
electrons
and then forces acting between them you
know the various physical forces
and then imposing a higher level
emergent description on those things to
say oh
there's a language in which we can talk
about human beings and tables and chairs
and this is very natural to us it's
automatic you don't need to really
teach children the philosophy of
emergence to get there
but it when you step back and try to
explain
well what are the principled reasons why
i take this
table to be an individual uh and not you
know the combination of this table and
the number five that's not
not a very good individual uh that's a
tricky kind of thing and
bringing up this porous nature of the
human self
uh highlights that trickiness yeah and
you know it's a
it's something that even young children
are quite
aware of you know you're right when you
say that we don't necessarily have to
learn it
we're aware of this sort of sense of
object permanence and you know young
children realize that one
object you know two objects cannot exist
in one space
and yet as you start to get into these
other trickier
sort of quantum questions which are
beyond my scope i would most certainly
say
um that that reality certainly begins to
blur
quite significantly and then you get to
ask those much deeper philosophical
questions so
i would wonder even from your
perspective um you know what kind of
lens you see the world through given
your background when you look at
physical reality and the
interconnectedness of things how do you
how do you sort of put that all together
yeah you know i'm a big believer in
emergence and levels of description
um in my whole book the big picture was
all about how
there are different vocabularies which
you can use to describe the world
one of them is there's just one big
quantum mechanical wave function
uh but then there's many others oh there
are particles and forces oh there are
chemicals oh there are cells and you
know
all these things and but it's it's the
sort of even though that's
natural to us it's it is not easy to say
why
it's so natural to us i mean clearly
part of the story is
it's there's an enormous amount of stuff
going on and we have to simplify right
we
have to uh coarse grain the world
into individual little objects to talk
about them like the story i tell is when
you go on a date with someone and they
say tell us about your tell me about
yourself
you don't list all of your atoms right
that's not a very
useful piece of information well at
cal tech we do but you know the rest of
the world it doesn't really happen that
much they're
in other words there's much more useful
information to give
than just a list of atoms even though
the list of atoms would be very
comprehensive by
by by sort of packaging the world into
these discrete units
we get leverage over it in a very useful
way and our brain does a lot of the work
for us right
so that's that's sort of what i was
interested in teasing apart too
is you know the taken for granted world
that we have that is sort of delivered
to us that we sort of take for granted
as this is the way it is when in fact
that
might not necessarily be the way it is
and
i don't know if we want to skip ahead
but of course you know the third chapter
is really looking at how different
animals and different species see the
world
and and from what biologists have been
able to uncover that's a very
different picture again using biological
systems and a biological lens to see the
world
uh you know a bat would see the world in
a completely different way than we would
yes thomas nagle famously wrote an
article right you know we all know that
it's hard to know what it's like to be a
bat
but i also i mean there's a the other
angle on the same question is
um you don't need to go to quantum
mechanics to see the importance of this
problem
artificial intelligence is faced with
this problem because computers don't
naturally divide the world up into
tables and chairs and and teaching them
the common sense that every baby knows
is a tricky thing
that's kind of the you know i mean
artificial intelligence certainly
has its biases and i'm quite troubled by
the way in which it's used especially in
in
surveillance states but it's interesting
to see
how artificial intelligence does parcel
out its
its pattern recognition is so
fundamentally different than ours right
that we don't even understand the logic
by which it comes to its conclusions and
yet it often does come to the right
conclusion that's a beautiful sort of
thing in itself
it is and it's beautiful on the
biological side too right like our
brains are not blank slates we're we're
built in with some way of thinking about
the world that turns out to be very
useful
yes yes especially i think you know
i mean we are still you know we haven't
evolved that much from
you know 70 000 years ago or 200 000
years ago we're still
these uh sort of neanderthals wearing
suits in a way sometimes i think you
know we still have
a lot of the same um biological senses
that our ancestors
did so you know i'm wearing i'm wearing
a little gizmo that i just recently
purchased it's it's a ring that is kind
of like a fitbit
it's a ring that sort of keeps track of
my sleep cycles and every morning i can
see you know how much time i spent in
rem sleep and light sleep and
when i was awake because the cats jumped
on me and stuff like that and
it is a brave new world of sensory
apprehension of our world right you know
we're
we human beings are sort of melding with
the technology that we're building to
give us different ways of thinking about
the world around us and ourselves
yes and you know i think the question
is uh and the deeper question is
obviously
what are those sensors for and who are
the powers who set up those sensors
ultimately and where is that data sort
of accumulated right because
your fitbit you know it's being sold to
you for the convenience of of you know
being able to monitor your heart or
where you're traveling or where you're
running or what have you but
ultimately the bigger question is the
database and and who owns the data
of all of our sensory knowledge our
combined collective sensory knowledge
today which is
sometimes of course used against us
absolutely
no and i do want to get there but but
there's one last thing i want to
cover on the sort of purely scientific
oh no i love that you're going step by
step it's fantastic yeah
but i mean there's a lot of steps so i i
don't want to you know
have wallow too much and you're reigning
me back in from
exactly from other chapters well the
other thing on the biological side that
you point to which i've often
you know uh thought about a lot is this
idea of scales
of time and space right you know we
pay attention not just to what's in
front of us but
to things that are the size that we are
right like we've already talked about
the mites or the microbes which are very
tiny
and we ignore things we don't pay as
much attention to the bigger things that
just look sort of smooth and homogeneous
to us but that's really interesting when
you get to time
right you know human beings have a
lifespan and we're very good at dealing
with things that happen on
month or year-long time scales but we're
really bad at things that happen on
thousand year long time skills much less
million year long time scales and
this kind of has implications for our
species
it absolutely does and um you know i
think that
this is sort of a cultural artifact
because i know that for example in
asian culture i'm half asian i'm
eurasian so my grandfather
is chinese and there's a much more sort
of cyclical
sort of dynastic sort of long-term
thinking
uh in asian culture my grandfather used
to participate in something known
as you know they were thousand-year-old
banquets and the thousand-year-old
banquets
would be a bunch of his friends that
were about 80 or 90 years old and they
would get together and together they
would be a thousand years old
for example right so there was always
that sort of thinking
um and also uh you know a friend of mine
joel solomon when he was working on uh
preserving the great bear rainforest
with many great activists
working in in the west coast of of
canada
when they were working on their project
they didn't come up with a five-year
plan or a 10-year plan
they came up with a 500-year plan which
is
you know when you're thinking about
ecosystems actually
a far more reflective and vital
time scale to be working in especially
when you're talking about trees that
live
a lot longer than we do so yeah there is
a sort of
human exceptionalism in the ways in
which we
we think about time
learning new things is incredibly
empowering knowing that you can do
better
feel better be better and i know from
personal experience that one of the best
ways to learn is from the great
courses plus a streaming service that
gives you unlimited access to thousands
of video lectures
on virtually anything that interests you
from tai chi to public speaking
one of my favorite courses is by
previous mindscape guest andre viscontis
you may remember we had a conversation
with andrei about music
and technology and neuroscience and her
course is called how digital technology
shapes us it explores our relationship
with artificial intelligence
robots and computing technology the
great courses plus has something for
everyone and it's all thoroughly vetted
fact-based information you can trust
from some of the best professors and top
experts in the fields
all over the world so sign up for the
great courses plus and find out
visit our special url the great courses
plus
dot com slash mindscape for a 14-day
trial with unlimited access for free
you don't want to pass this up so go now
to th e
great courses plus dot com slash
mindscape
is there any sort of um
uh advice or you know operational way
that we can
extend our thinking in some way you know
there's we we've all heard
that climate change is happening right
um but it still happens slowly like you
can stand out
on the beach and look at the pacific
ocean and it's not actually rising as
you see it and that lack of immediacy
and vividness
makes it difficult for people to really
worry about this maybe as much as we
should
yeah i mean that's really one of the the
greatest
challenges is the fact that this is a
slow apocalypse that we're
witnessing right and usually in a horror
movie or something the monster comes at
you really quickly and you have to be
very nimble with your responses but yeah
human beings don't tend to respond quite
as well
with uh longer time scales which is why
you know when we're talking about what
we're facing today as an emergency
but our plans are are not reflective of
that when we're
when we're setting dates and targets
that are 10 years
20 years ahead you know 2040 2050 is
when we
have our plans then there's a sort of
disjointed
approach to being able to really treat
the situation that we're in as an
emergency
and it's both space as well as time that
that we have this issue with right um
there's a
the famous statement that uh one death
is a tragedy a million deaths is
a statistic right if the million deaths
are happening far away
it's just hard to get as emotionally
invested in them and and maybe this
makes biological sense from that 70 000
year old perspective and maybe it
doesn't anymore maybe this is something
we're going to have to
change our uh uh evolve out of in some
way
well i do quite a bit of work with
different um environmental organizations
i'm
uh on the i'm a trustee i'm on the board
of wwf international and
i worked with wwf in canada for eight
years and so
i've been doing a lot of thinking over
time over how do you
how do you actually get people to care
you know i think you can probably tell
from this book i didn't want to write i
mean i certainly did not want to write
an environmental book and i
barely used the word environment when i
wrote the entire book i think i
managed to write an entire book without
doing it so that i could put the word in
when i wanted to at the end
um but at the same time one thing that
did strike me
is the fact that um when you're dealing
with that statistic question of you know
a million deaths versus one
one of the best ways to reach people is
just by telling them the story of one
person
um and in fact there have been studies
that have been done that if
you even let's say if there's an
earthquake and you just tell the story
of one person in that earthquake um
you're able to get far more people
responding
to that one person than if it's even two
people and
that's one of the things that i wrote
about too in the book is the sense of
scale blindness
and people have done studies on this you
know if you have for example just
hypothetical seabirds let's say you have
um
8 000 or 80 000 or 800
000 um people respond in almost the
exact same way
they'll donate seven dollars or eight
dollars or seven dollars you know what i
mean they can't even differentiate even
when
uh the difference is seven thousand
versus seven hundred
thousand seabirds that are covered in
oil slicks for example so
um as the numbers start to get really
big
we do have uh you know a perceptual
blindness we're not able to really pick
that up or differentiate it and that's
because
you know as cave people we never really
needed to we were never dealing in the
billions when we were out in the
savannah
hunting yeah literally the as you say in
the book
our ability to accurately conceptualize
really big numbers is kind of pitifully
bad we're just not very good at that
right
yeah we're not but our machines are and
so you know today
you know when we see all this stuff
going on with these high-frequency
traders
they're also trading and and working
with time for example and figures and
numbers that are
just vastly beyond what we're able to
perceive
you know like you can basically send a
signal across
the atlantic you know uh there and back
something like six times in the time
that you know you
i've said the word go you know so it's
incredible the speed at which we
at which we work and which we operate
and our computers operate
and there's a guy named sal arnica i
liked his quote because he was saying
you know
by the time you know a normal person
looks at a stock
like a high frequency stock it's like a
star that burned out 50 000 years ago
our computers are working so quickly and
with such big
massive numbers and at such high speeds
that we can't perceive that this is
um i believe what jeremy rifkin referred
to as computing
you know a sort of time that is just
beyond human perception
yeah and it's uh i mean this is this
whole conversation is a list of ways the
human brain is just not that good
in some ways it's really good at some
point we are meat flesh but we've done
we've done well
we've done well overall in terms of like
scaling things up and developing tools
um you know it's just a bit ironic that
we're sort of you know
we develop tools that have destructive
effects and then we develop tools that
detect that we have destructive effects
all right let's hope we're able to catch
up with ourselves pat on the head to the
human beings we have done some good
things
but okay then there's this conceptual
shift i think
at least from where i'm coming from the
way that i think about it in
the part of your book that sort of we've
covered where
human sensory apparatus and conceptual
apparatus
filters out some things about the world
and pays attention to other things and
then
there's this shift where we say it's not
just like the physical
stuff or in by physical i include you
know biological
mites and things like that there's
conceptual stuff
that we that we filter out and what it
reminded me of is
uh you know we went my wife and i went
on a uh
a power boat ride out of muna del rey
last summer when you could do
not last summer but a year and a half
ago when you do these things
last year and the importance of you know
it's just a couple hours on a boat
but the boat is a little ecosystem right
all by itself like
you can't on the boat call for takeout
right you're out there you need to bring
everything and be able to dispose of
everything
and it's something we usually don't pay
attention to and you know one of the
most vivid chapters in your book is
about
where our food comes from so why don't
you tell us what what do you think
is the take-home message here wow okay
well that's a that's a big one
um and of course food is is something
that is both
the most comforting thing in the world
for us because we're growing up you know
with our families and our familial
recipes and it's how we all come
kind of come together around the
proverbial and the very literal
fire but also our food system is
so damaging to the way uh and
actually jeopardizes our very existence
on earth right now
one aspect of course that you know that
i start getting into
in the book is what i a friend of mine
actually quote the term the jiz biz
which is really about the business of um
semen sales right because really
um we've hijacked we've hijacked
um the the sort of reproductive systems
of a lot of different animals so today
about 95
of pigs and 90 of cows um
never really get to do it the
old-fashioned way
they are they are you know they're
created through
in vitro fertilization in fact every
single turkey that you'll ever
eat is um something that humans got into
the middle
of and sort of messed with and we've
sort of um
basically hijacked their reproductive
system so that we can take it over
yeah and so that we can turn animals
fundamentally into these products
uh that we consume and in doing so
um of course today i think many people
are aware that they're
you know we have three to four percent
wildlife
and the rest of the vertebrate biomass
on our planet is our domesticated
animals and human beings
so we've had our finger on the dial and
we've been cranking it up
and every year now we kill 60 to 70
billion animals every single year
but when we talk about blind spots the
real issue is that we don't see any of
it
we see none of it right you know um and
i sit on another board
of a of an organization that i'm so
happy to tout because they do such
incredible work
it's called we animals and it was
started by a photojournalist named
joanne mcarthur and i just
highly recommend anybody who's listening
to go check out her work she's been
doing this for years
she goes everywhere she documents the
life of animals
as they become products in a sense
whether it's you know
harvesting bears for bile in china or
animals and zoos but of course
a lot of animals and factory farms and
when we talk about this notion of
disgust
and disgustology we don't look there
anymore we've moved factory farms very
far away
from us and so we don't see when there's
disease or
or animal cruelty unless there's some
sort of investigative episode every once
in a while on an investigative show that
will document it
but these photojournalists actually do
go in there
and they document a lot of this so that
we can actually see what is happening to
these
you know intelligent sentient beings and
in places like ontario where i live i
live in toronto
um we've just instituted ag laws which
you may have heard of which are
laws that make it illegal to actually go
and document
any of this um any of these abuses that
are taking place
but when we talked about that
uncomfortable truth these are things
that we should really want to be able to
see
if we want to create a better world so
i hope that kind of explains in a
nutshell a very small part
of the broken food system which is one
of the three cycles that i talk about i
talk about
the life cycle being broken the death
cycle being broken and the rebirth cycle
being broken
so that's really food energy and waste
yeah let me actually just
tease out even more about this fact of
the
difficulty slash illegality of
documenting what goes on
inside uh these factory farms because um
as i started saying out as we started
talking about you you may or may not be
happy or content or or accepting of what
goes on in them
but there's another thing to say well
you should be not allowed to know
and that's that seems like harder to
justify is there is there some
principled case for
not allowing people to know how their
food is made
exactly you would hope that your food
system would be the most transparent
system of all right
yeah and um i think it's margaret
heffernan that i quoted in the book
when she talks about willful blindness
this notion that
something has to actually be really
really bad if you don't even want to
know how bad it is
you know a lot of people are like don't
tell me about what goes on in factory
farms i don't want to know and they kind
of cover their eyes and
and i've i've had a lot of experience
with that i mean
i um on twitter i post animal animal
images all the time and
and they're my most retweeted tweets
right um
you know if i if i show you know a
siphonophore or some beautiful
you know seahorse or whatever it might
be people
love animals on the internet and they
say that they love animals
holy cow if you try to actually talk
about anything to do with what happens
to animals kind of behind the scenes
oh people people don't like that and i
will instantly lose
followers it happens every time and i
continuously do it because
you know that's not a good reason to to
to tweet is by monitoring your follower
account
so i still will tweet but i will notice
that if you actually
share the truth the very uncomfortable
truth
of what we do to our fellow species
um people people don't like to see that
so you have to be really careful and you
know that was
that was why when i structured the book
to be perfectly transparent about how i
structured the book i hope future
readers don't mind but
i came into the food chapter only after
really talking about the wonder
and the enchantment of all the different
ways in which animals are intelligent
or able to see so that we remind
ourselves
of of you know our fellow earthlings and
how incredible they are
they're just as incredible as when
you're watching them on a david
attenborough sort of
life on earth or blue planet documentary
you know if you're watching blue planet
and you see the sailfish they're so
beautiful
and and and incredible and awe inspiring
um but then if you were to watch them on
a fishing show you suddenly you know
what i mean you
the idea of them as products when you
see them all being pulled up in those
nets
we forget that they're still those
beautiful enchanting creatures that we
were admiring on another channel just
moments ago
and you have many uh examples very vivid
examples in the book i mean maybe
just to pick out one to fix ideas uh
it's maybe
a hackneyed example but still a good one
and it's the chicken nugget
uh very different thing than an actual
piece of chicken
is is what you consume when you eat a
chicken nugget
yeah i mean i found a a study
that was with scientists who did an
autopsy on a chicken nugget
because they wanted to actually see
what's in the chicken nugget and what
they discovered of course was that a
chicken nugget is very little
actual uh chicken meat um and it's
actually just you know the sort of sinew
and muscle and fat that people
are consuming they were doing this as
part of an obesity
study but as i started looking into that
i really wanted to look at how meat
actually became
deconstructed and all the different ways
in which
meat is um delivered to us in ways that
uh in in ways that kind of fool our
senses again
and so you know one of the examples that
uh you'll remember from the book is the
notion of the samoa fan which is
uh developed by dsm and the samo fan
is a fan it looks like if you went to a
hardware store and you pulled out those
paint chips and you can see all the
different colors that you want to paint
your wall
except this is a a color paint chip
for salmon because of course farm salmon
doesn't eat all the krill um and all the
you know all the sort of rich goodness
that gives salmon
that pink color so if you didn't
actually
uh taint their food source with a
particular color
their flesh would be gray but nobody's
going to go to the supermarket and want
to buy
gray salmon so we have ways
of um sort of tricking the eye and the
same thing happens with egg yolks as
well right so we kind of have this idea
this illusion that oh it's an orange egg
yolk it must be really really farm fresh
and if you're not buying it from your
local farmer there's a very good chance
that that's a
you know an artificially colored egg
yolk
and it's an example of how probably
the instincts we have that a pink salmon
a yellow egg yolk
a bright red apple or something like
that
instinctively we think that that's fresh
and beautiful and
healthy and maybe it was a few hundred
years ago
but now the the the whether or not this
is a particularly
healthy piece of salmon and what it
looks like have just become completely
separated because we can manipulate that
and that's dangerous right i mean it's
not actually the process that's
dangerous as what it's disguising
it's that chemical blindness that's
dangerous so you know
another example that you know i talk
about in the book is
is the use of carbon monoxide on tuna so
they use carbon monoxide to give
that fish the fish that sort of bright
red color that people really like if
they're buying sushi or buying red tuna
for example
but what it's disguising is that that
that fish might be a year old
might be you know might have been frozen
and thawed multiple times and that
becomes really quite dangerous because
then you could get sick from that fish
and you wouldn't know it because it
would look super fresh
but it's actually a really old piece of
flesh
and there's just an argument to be made
isn't there that
on strictly sort of moral grounds uh
i should it should be okay for me to ask
questions and get the answers
about what my what is actually in my
food and what i'm eating right like
just a late like there's controversy
over whether or not you have to label
what the ingredients are
in something or the or the nutritional
information and
i just can't see the principled
objection to knowing how many calories i
have in my
food but you know i can see why the
businesses don't want it because i will
confess there are restaurants in the
united states that i no longer go
to because since they started putting
the calorie counts on their dishes i'm
like oh my god i'm going to die if i
keep eating
yeah yeah but i think that you're right
i mean i think the
you know the ability to know and that's
why the book i mean thankfully
and i'm grateful to have a wonderful
editor too you know there was no finger
wagging in the book i didn't want to say
this is how you should think or this is
how you should eat it's just really a
question of like
wouldn't you want to know this right i
certainly would
yeah she'd be able to make an informed
decision and then there's
you you talk a lot about you know okay
so where the food comes from and that's
kind of a mystery box in our current
culture but then
what happens when it goes also there's
questions of you know the waste that we
produce in the world whether it's
organic or just
trash and plastics and so forth and we
tend not to ask very hard questions
about that either
yeah and for me the most staggering
statistic one of the most staggering
statistics that i came across
is the fact that in terms of all the
food waste
um in the states it's the equivalent of
if you just like all the energy and oil
if you just stopped all the offshore
drilling in the united states it would
be the equivalent of that right because
that's how much food we waste that's how
much energy we waste
to create the food that we end up
throwing away
um and that's that's absolutely the
enormity of that
is is mind-boggling to me and um
so yeah i mean food waste is certainly
something and of course
the even the utensils with which we use
uh to eat our food
there's that well-known meme on the
internet right this idea
that the energy that is used to go off
to a foreign land
probably wage war and then extract the
oil and then refine the oil and then
transport the oil
and then you know turn and then turn you
know part of that
part of that into you know creating
plastics for example
and then shaping and molding the plastic
and then distributing the plastic and
then
getting a plastic spoon and then eating
some yogurt
and then throwing that spoon away is so
much more energy than just
washing a freaking spoon you know so it
is
yeah we are not very efficient despite
our
our very um global efficiency
efficiencies that we built into our
infrastructure i suppose
well this this harkens to something that
we'll we'll get to later and you get to
later in the book but maybe it's worth
bringing up now
that uh when you do when your attention
is drawn to some of these features of
the world we live in and you might find
them
uh not to your liking you might want to
you know rebel against them but most of
the time
it's not because there's some evil
genius manipulating things in the
background it is kind of a
self-organized system in many ways it's
many little
micro incentives have led us to here and
they may or may not
be leading us to an efficient outcome
even by
the most basic of criteria
well human beings you know we are
separate from all the other species
because we developed a
quote-unquote system which is what a lot
of this book sort of looks at right
we're always like fight the system
you've got to change the system but
nobody actually asks what that system is
and that system
is our life support system and
we are different because we've
manufactured systems that make us more
efficient so we're not beholden to the
cycles of nature anymore
we're only beholden to our own machinery
and the problem is that we got too good
at it
we got so good at it that we're actually
outstripping
the ability for nature to provide the
the input which is the actual you know
the resources that actually make up all
of our food and our energy
and we're not you know we're not sort of
dancing along with nature's cycles
either
in in the ways in which um nature is
able to recycle
all of those inputs and outputs and so
that's what part of the
the damage is the machine that we've
created is
is a little bit well not a little bit
very very wildly out of whack at this
point in time
well and speaking of the systems that we
construct as human beings you have a
couple of chapters
uh that were interesting to me because i
wouldn't have expected to find them in
the kind of book you're writing but they
sort of made sense after the fact
about time and space you know these
grids
that we human beings impose on the world
and then we sort of
get used to them and treat them as
natural so i mean maybe i shouldn't talk
and i should let you explain what you
have in mind
when you're talking about these things
well i i just started you know i mean
that was the question once you have the
system that's completely out of whack
you have to ask yourself well we made
the system so why are we not able to fix
the system
and that's when i really wanted to look
into those intergenerational blind spots
those sort of civilizational blind spots
that we were chatting about earlier
and to do that i felt we needed to look
into the blind spots of time and space
and the ways in which as human beings we
have
um created systems
that that scale time and space in some
sense into a human scale right because
we know time is sort of this big
infinite thing from the big bang well
into some sort of
future singularity and space is
absolutely enormous but we're given what
we're given on the planet
and given our you know minute time
scales as human beings on our
on our lives and and we've chopped up
time and space
um and we've turned time and space these
vast dimensions
into these little measures that we can
buy and sell amongst each other
so of course you know the most
simplistic version of that is the way in
which
we've chopped up time into a human clock
that we can
buy and sell each other's time um such
that some people's time like
jeff bezos is like i don't know however
many hundreds of millions of dollars he
makes per day
versus a delete who makes maybe you know
a few pennies a day
um and our space as well we've chopped
up the dimension of space
such that you know some people today are
inhabiting ghost mansions and other
people
are living in the equivalent of spatial
coffins
um and and that's really the big picture
overview
of of how we have uh chopped up time in
space but of course
going into the book that's the political
dimension but i'm always looking at it
from sort of a scientific dimension of
how did we kind of get there how did we
how did we you know develop all these
sorts of measurements and
i've always been kind of fascinated by
that too so that's that's another part
of the story that gets us in there
the curators at bespoke post have done
it again this winter with an all new
lineup of essential box of awesome
collections that are guaranteed to
upgrade your life
whether it's showcase pieces to level up
your indoor hosting skills
or cozy threads for those blustery days
bespoke post
only sends you the best stuff every
month from style and grooming goods to
bar wear
cooking tools and outdoor gear box of
awesome has collections for every part
of your life
for my life the one i like is their
cocktail smoking kit
if you like your cocktails you can take
your negroni manhattan margarita what
have you
and make it better by infusing it with a
true smoky aroma
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time
every box from box of awesome costs only
45 bucks
but has over 70 dollars worth of gear
inside
so get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome dot
com and enter the code
mindscape at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com
code mindscape for 20 off your first box
yeah and almost despite yourself some of
these ways that we have
uh of chopping things up that you talk
about are
quite charming like the idea of the
smell clock
i i really uh was sort of compelled by
i kind of want to get myself a clock
that will let me know what time of day
it is by how things smell in the room
which kind of incense is burning yeah
and that's that's the way
uh you know chinese people used to be
able to get people to
know what time it was or what time it
was to uh
to go to the temple was by changing the
incense and having different incense
clocks and i love that there
over time there have been different you
know this notion uh that linnaeus came
up with of a flower clock
of being able to tell the time by
different blooms
and people who have come up with um bird
you know the sound of birds and uh
different you know because they
they chirp and they rise at different
times so if you were if you were so well
attuned you would know what time it was
by
by knowing uh the sound of which bird
was singing outside of your window
so there's many different ways in which
we've approached uh
time for example i think i mentioned in
the book um
in madagascar they measure time by uh by
a cricket frying
like how long it takes to fry a cricket
and
and through most of human history time
has been a an event-driven
process um how long it takes to fry that
cricket or to make a bowl of rice
as opposed to this very rigid idea of
time now which is the synchronous time
that comes to
us you know beamed from a satellite that
we're all marching to
um that we we seldom think about now so
it's really how did we
get to be trained uh out of a natural
cycle
and into a modern system and those are
the sorts of questions that i really
wanted to address because
they're scientific questions science
brought us here
um so i just think that that that needs
a little bit more reflection i'm a big
i'm a big proponent of you know
polymaths right because i really
always think that you know science
without humanity sort of lacks humanity
and i think that you know
early science sort of was very um it had
this really objectifying notion and i
would really love to see the the
humanity
part of it come back in you know i've
always felt
um some urge to stand up
for clocks and the measurement of time
there there's almost a cliched idea
that you know you can be a slave to the
clock right like
in the modern world rather than living
our lives we're
beholden to this artificial thing uh but
part of me
yeah i'm gonna try this out on you here
but part of me wants to think
uh you know if you were the only person
in the world
then what time it is wouldn't matter
except for maybe you know your crops and
whatever then it's not very accurate but
the usefulness of time
measuring time and and having clocks all
around us
is that we're not the only person in the
world that we synchronize our activities
with others so i would say like the
happy side
of measuring time is that it enables a
whole kind of
social cooperation that we wouldn't
otherwise be able to experience
oh for sure i mean there's absolutely
the sense that before clocks came along
meetings were very difficult you know
you would you'd pretty much be like okay
we're meeting at 6 00 a.m at dawn or
we're meeting at dusk or we're meeting
at high noon
i mean there's only choices yeah that
many options and certainly
uh synchrony is a beautiful thing but i
think again
uh it's it's how time has been used we
can't sort of uh
it doesn't exist in that wonderful
isolation and so it's really when
when we became beholden to other
people's time
or to corporate time or to state time or
to industry time
and the book does go into how that you
know the the emergence of
master and slave clocks which is what
they were literally called
that sort of totalitarian authoritarian
time that has sort of seeped into us
and of course without giving too much
away the resultant effects that our own
human machine made time has now had
on biological systems such that such
that nature is out of whack
you know you're starting to see birds
now that are that are flying
and i don't know if you saw recently in
the news how many birds died of
starvation did you see that
the the migrating birds no oh
it was in the news and i i don't know if
it's attributed to this particular
example of phenology
and you know phenology is sort of like
the timing in nature but we're seeing a
lot more mismatches now
of you know used to be the early bird
gets the worm well now when you've got
you know
flowers and trees blooming a lot earlier
and insects coming earlier
when you actually finally have the bird
migration
the birds are all late right and so the
birds are all starving
and so that's that's actually a result
of how we have structured our time um
and it's incredible so so so it's it's
pretty strange that something that seems
sort of imaginary and seems sort of
poetic in some way can actually
restructure the temporal systems of
nature
is this because our human influence has
changed the
flowering and growth cycles of the
plants
yes well i mean we've ultimately the
ways in which our human systems
um have become so efficient and
hyperproductive and used so much
energy that of course we've created
climate change
and climate change is something that is
affecting plants
and plant blooming times and all those
sorts of things yeah so you know i
looked up in the
index of your book um the name michel
foucault
because it seemed like there was a lot
of
resonance there so it appeared but it
was only like one glancing kind of
reference were you
at all heavily influenced by him or did
you just sort of are you
fellow travelers in some sense um you
know
i wouldn't say heavily influenced
although if i peek over
right over here and i look on my
bookshelf i can see that i have the book
power here by foucault but um but no
i wouldn't say altogether influence
certainly i i read
foucault um when i was in university
um but but not not necessarily no i
wouldn't say so and i think that's
probably reflective of the fact that
there's only one
little quote in there but i think i
would like to write a book on power
very much that would be my next topic
and and uh i think
then then i think i'm going to crack
open that old foucault book and take a
take a better look well i thought it was
a fascinating move in your book where
you went from
you know the the sort of direct physical
science of what we can perceive about
the world
and then the sort of dynamical
infrastructure in which we find
ourselves uh embedded and yet
don't pay attention to different aspects
of it and then in the final section of
the book you're talking about
invisible power structures right that
really only exist in human minds yet
exert an enormous effect over how we
live
our lives and how we what we consider to
be good bad right and wrong
common weird right and and the
manifestation of that you know in early
days was of course
the panopticon but the panopticon has
become real so
right uh you know talking all you know
it starts off really looking at where
we're blind and where we can't see and
then sort of really questioning well why
is it that
now we've also created a state where the
eyes are all turned on us
we're blind but we're also so deeply and
heavily surveyed
and and of course why would that be why
would that be
and so much of it as to keep us
conforming to the
system that we've built and to not stray
or to not not
go too far out of line well i first read
about the panopticon when i was reading
foucault as an undergraduate that's what
made me uh
think of it and he wrote about in
discipline and punish
right right right exactly exactly but
you're right yeah
you make a very vivid point about the
surveillance and you know the the
statistic that you
quote which hopefully you can elaborate
on is that 75
of united states companies in one way or
the other
are looking in on their employees as
they work
did i have that i mean i wrote the book
a couple years ago so i wouldn't know
what the
the statistic is today but i mean you
know
that that wouldn't surprise me at all
because there are
i mean it's there's so many different
forms of surveillance right
sure and i talk about so many of those
different forms in the book so it isn't
just
say having a camera on you although that
is the most basic form of surveillance
so it would easily be 75
now if you think of any single workplace
that you go into you'll see one of those
black orbs on the ceiling or you'll see
cameras but of course there's deeper
levels of surveillance that we see
as well right you see that with uh if
you're a trucker
all of your truck stops are monitored
and surveyed
gosh in china the level of surveillance
is is such that they even have people
wearing helmets
uh to monitor monitor whether they're
focused or paying attention um
so yeah surveillance is incredibly
incredibly deep
and and i lay out a lot of that
because i think that the average person
still is not aware
of the degree to which surveillance
seeps in i think that we had the snowden
revelation several years ago
and there's always the old refrain of
you know if i'm not doing anything wrong
then why should it matter and i think
that hopefully by the time the reader
finishes the book you you definitely get
a sense that uh
it's not about that it's not about uh
what you're doing it's it's simply about
who you are
if you're the wrong category of person
right with the flip of a switch for
example even when trump
obviously had power um you know if you
happen to be muslim
if in another country you happen to be
gay if you happen to
to think a certain way or have a certain
political alignment
well there's a lot of data on you now
and uh that data can be used against you
and like we said before with the million
deaths being a statistic versus one
story being compelling um
the either the individual anecdotes
really bring it home and one of the
things you mentioned is that several
cities
uh including las vegas one of my
favorite cities uh
have if i'm gonna get it right uh in the
street lamps there's not only video
cameras but audio recording devices
eavesdropping on the conversations of
people walking down the streets
yeah yeah intelligence intellisystems i
believe had those um i haven't checked
on them very recently but certainly you
know that reminds me of um
the lion the witch and the wardrobe
whenever i came across that
you know the sense that you could be in
the forest and and
you know trees could be spying on you
and of course today
um it's not just your lamp posts i mean
sometimes it's your kettle
sometimes when you're walking in a store
we haven't done this for the past year
but it's mannequins
i mean there are sensors and
surveillance and camera systems
just about everywhere and of course you
know the ones that we pay the least
amount of attention to are the ones that
we carry in our pockets or that we stare
into in our laptops every single day
um but yeah absolutely uh we have a lot
of them
everywhere well this is the the joke
going around
on twitter is that people are afraid of
the idea that bill gates is going to
implant microchips
in the coronavirus uh vaccine
but you know they but they go out and
spend hundreds of dollars to carry
around microchips in their phones that
are actually tracking them
it's like i don't know why you would
need to have the yeah you wouldn't need
to be microchipped you're already
carrying the surveillance device in your
hand
absolutely i i laughed at that when i
saw that as well
i mean we we do know that our phones
know where we are physically
in space do we know how much
control we have over that data i mean
they try to hide it from us i know that
but uh
you know i can turn off location
services who gets this data who uses it
do we have any idea
well all different actors use it um you
know
whether it's state actors or or you know
whether it's
companies trying to buy for you to buy
buy
buy buy so that we all become
hyper-consuming beasts
or you know security agencies who are
you know hired security firms who are
hired to track down individuals again i
i mentioned the film dissident only
because i saw it
you know just a couple nights ago but
here's a situation where
you know a young man here in montreal
was using his phone to chat with
khashoggi and
he had received a piece of malware from
the saudi government
and they had access to absolutely every
single thing on his phone
and it wasn't benign at all it resulted
in a a
very gruesome death um
of of a person who was an advocate for
for free speech in the middle east so um
you know these these little eyes can be
used to silence us in in very big ways
and you mentioned the famous example of
cambridge analytica that not only
tracked people on facebook but tracked
the friends of the people who answered
these quizzes and so forth
yeah a lot of scraping as we're aware
and so
you know that's one of the things that
we have to think about today it's not
like
it's not like cambridge analytica and
any of those tools which we're not just
spying on people
but looking at their preferences and
looking at their psychological
weaknesses
uh see you know to be able to shape
behavior it's the fact that now that
that's
part of the way in which quote-unquote
business is done
um that's still being used you know we
have all these bots we have all these
trolls
um and we have all these ways of shaping
opinion
and they haven't gone away they've just
been sort of tucked under the surface
for right now so
it's important that we don't look away
that we don't turn a blind eye
to those mechanisms that are they're
still out there in force
but it's interesting to think about how
people react
to knowing this i mean you brought up
the example of china uh
where it's it's more even more extreme
than i guess we're used to here in the
u.s the extent to which the government
uh tracks i think i think you talked
about again correct me if i'm wrong
uh that there are monitors in
hats that you wear and if you work in
certain chinese industries where they're
basically keeping track of your brain
waves
yeah well i mean and i again being half
chinese like i
i write about the uyghurs in the book
and i have a huge problem
with the chinese state and its
surveillance system but at the same time
i'm also really against the hyper
demonization of china that i'm starting
to see because
china does some amazing stuff too you
know a state is not necessarily
its people and i'm also marvel at like
the chinese engineers who've been able
to create their incredible you know 300
000 kilometer you know bullet train
system and i kind of wish that we would
look to china cooperatively
for some of those technologies because i
i think it would be just a godsend
and a wonder if in the states we could
have have high-speed bullet trains
uh as we do in china and i think that
china again when we talked about the
sort of cyclical
dynastic sort of structure and way of
thinking is very different
this is not to excuse chinese state
surveillance which
as i said and as i will emphasize again
and again i don't agree with
but i do think that the chinese have a
very different
way of thinking that wow i mean it's
tricky it's tricky i'm eurasian so i
have
i have that sort of built into my mind
um
how they see the world and i just i
don't demonize it
quite so much you know i mean they have
what is it now 1.6 billion people
and chinese culture is a very collective
culture
and it's really one of the reasons why
you know today when we look at kovid
there's two viruses right there's a
physical virus and there's a mind virus
and the mind virus is this anti-vax
anti-mask virus that
we have going quite strong here uh in
the states and in canada
i'll tell you that virus is not in in
china
you know what i mean for better or for
worse that that mind virus does not
spread over there it doesn't have the
opportunity to
quite possibly because it has been
clamped down um
but when you have to look at i get
i'm guessing i'm totally guessing here
but i'm thinking
if you're a chinese leader and you know
that
you're kind of responsible for 1.6
billion primates on earth
and that they can't kind of go
completely haywire
i can sort of understand why such a
surveillance system would be put in
place because chinese people
have a lot of sense of filial piety and
conformity
and and collective sort of response so
the surveillance system there is kind of
it it's quite different culturally um
than how we perceive it i don't know if
that makes sense or not but
um it's hard for us to put our sort of
western values on on
on chinese culture no it does in fact i
did a recent podcast with joe henrik uh
a psychologist anthropologist at harvard
who talks about the weird societies
right western educated
industrialized rich democratic and how
they are very different and how
we tend to treat our norms and morals as
universals
but they're not you know there are
different modes of being so but i was
actually not going to be judgey about
china i think that's a complicated
question that i mean
i don't think you were i was just i was
actually expecting something i wanted to
vent because i just feel like sometimes
we see that a lot on
that's why we're here so that means my
side of it is
one might think given what you just said
about the differences between
western culture and chinese culture or
whatever uh
that we rugged western individualists
would just who live in nominally
democracies where we get to choose what
the laws are we would never let it
happen
that we're constantly surveilled and our
data is constantly kept because we're
very private and you know we want to
keep that stuff but in fact
most people are like ah you know i'd
rather have google maps
tell me where to go and not undergo the
inconvenience of not telling it where i
am so it's there's sort of a collective
action problem right even we don't quite
live up to our own stated
uh ways of thinking about this and we
are equally surveilled and we're so
equally surveilled such that you know
um we've seen the impact of that
surveillance be able to nearly
topple democracy very very recently you
know whether it was brexit or whether it
was the voting in of donald trump you
know cambridge analytica had a very big
uh part to play in that and that has to
do with
surveillance culture right the ability
to shape opinion
based on surveilled data
so yeah like we're talking about 20
different topics all of which deserve a
podcast all their own so i i apologize
to listeners who think that we're
skipping over but one last thing i did
want to
talk about and it's a this it's a big
deep
provocative idea just about the way that
i would put it is
the idea that we invent
laws and political systems and economic
systems and
they develop and they evolve into
certain kinds of structures and then
once they're there we kind of treat them
as natural even though
you know in some objective way they're
not only not natural but sort of wildly
uh unequal and and maybe not very good
for many people so
that's all very vague but i wanted to
let you comment or put that into your
own words
sure i mean one example
um you know when you talk about sort of
all these laws and
let's call them imaginary systems almost
because they're human constructions and
how they sort of tend to trump
um natural reality in many ways
i think for me the most in chap most
important chapter in the book is the
final chapter and it is the chapter that
sort of
brings all the other chapters hopefully
together i'm not going to give it away
because i hope some of your listeners
will become readers but it is the main
sort of um main purpose really
even of of writing the book um but one
of the things that's an example of what
you just said
um is kind of illustrated in in one
story that i kind of came across and
it's about the
little mahoning watershed i don't know
if you remember reading about that but
there's a oh yeah a bunch of activists
and
and this watershed um they were it was
getting fracked
and so like many different places around
the world right now
um some of the activists were trying to
get rights for this watershed so um i
don't know if you know but like
there's a river in in new zealand that
um
basically kind of owns itself now it has
rights
uh just as there's a part of the amazon
basin that has rights
um so that you know human beings can't
sort of just trample all over it it has
some legal
uh legal rights sorry just to be super
clear about this
you you mean not the people of that area
have those rights but the literal
part of the earth has those rights yeah
it's i think the technical term is sort
of like
uh ordinances of nature um so
the actual the actual river has
um almost a form of personhood if we
might put it that way
such that it could go to court and sort
of fight for its own existence
um so they were fighting for this um at
the little mahoning watershed
and in the states um i can't remember
which state it was exactly but the the
judge threw it out and the judge was
just
furious with the lawyers for saying that
you know
making up this artificial idea that this
watershed should have rights
and what i loved about the legal
response to that
was the fact that they pointed out well
who's fighting us in this
court case it's a corporation you're
trying to tell us that a corporation is
more
real right than a river or than a
watershed
or than an ecosystem and um
so that for me was a little bit profound
in the sense of
you know these these sort of organized
systems and structures that we have
and the power that we've given them to
sort of reorder
our natural world today and and the need
for us to sort of look a little bit more
deeply at that
that's of course not the chapter i don't
want to give it away there's more
there's more than that
that's a little small teaser about it
well yeah you know my personal attitude
is that
uh by and large i'm a fan of the idea
for example of private property uh
in in some cases but i completely
uh think that it's a something we
invented right like we
we tend to invent it and then treat it
as sacred and handed down
from an objective feature of the
universe but we did invent it and
presumably we invented it
for reasons and if that uh
concept ends up being used in ways that
go against what the original reasons
were
then we should rethink our attitude
toward it yeah
absolutely and of course you know we
came up with this invention
um at a time when we had a very
different uh population
here on earth and i think we're
definitely going to
need to re-evaluate some of our our
inventions like private property in the
future if we're all to be able to
cohabit
together so it may not be a return to
the commons as we knew it but uh
something something different than what
we have today for sure
and it is hard in part because of what
we started talking about where
human beings are not very good at
conceptualizing things that are way
bigger or older or more numerous than
ourselves so
you know when you have this idea that
one person
has a net worth uh a million times or
much more than that the net worth of
another person economically speaking
uh it's just hard to know what to make
of that in some sense
yeah again you know that kind of comes
down to those artificial
rules of the game that we've made up you
know when we talk about private property
here on earth it's it's funny
you know when you read the outer space
treaty because the outer space treaty is
the one province that is open to all
mankind
and it's like well what good is that you
know like point zero zero zero zero six
seven percent of us have made it to
outer space but that is the province
that we have not
actually you know divvied up and
parceled up that one person can own it
or another person can't
um so so a lot of a lot of it is really
quite absurd
well i wonder okay here's the last
questions then um a lot of what we're
talking about here
uh is extraordinarily relevant to our
lives here
on earth right now but it will
presumably
be deeply affected by technological
changes in the future whether it's
we will go to the moon and mars and
start living there or whether it's
we will uh grow our meat in vats rather
than
on farms uh do you want to speculate a
little bit
for how you think uh this this view of
the world and the reality bubble
uh is subject to change in the near and
far future
sure yeah um you know it's funny because
i did just write an article
uh for pop-up magazine on this very sort
of topic
um and i think that you know one of the
things certainly as you mentioned
that excites me the most is cellular
agriculture
because it's incredible that you know
today we've been able to
sort of separate the animal from the
flesh
right uh the fact that you know i was
watching this video
of just which uh just as some of your
listeners may know they basically
opened up uh singapore has has sort of
validated uh cellular agriculture there
and and so they have all these
scientists and and
um they had this chicken and i can't
remember the name of the chicken right
now so let's just call the chicken head
and basically they took a they took you
know some stem cells from a feather that
had fallen from this perfect bird
and and they manufactured meat with it
they put it in a bioreactor
grew the cells and and grew chicken meat
chicken breast chicken flesh
and the entire just team is sitting
around
eating chicken burgers for lunch and the
bird
the perfectly unharmed bird that they're
all eating
is walking around and just sort of
clucking around them completely unharmed
and so the ability to put these
bioreactors in different places
where there is food scarcity to be able
to produce milk to be able to produce
protein
you know to reduce the you know the
water footprint the
the methane footprint the animal cruelty
all these sorts of things is is just
fantastic
you know um it's definitely a win-win
sort of situation
and for me you know one of the things
that you know
um i've been thinking about lately is
you know so many of us are indoors now
and um
we don't have this sort of 24 7
lifestyle that we used to have
and i grew up in hong kong um in my
early years
and and uh you know when i was up until
the age of 11
and we used to have 7-eleven when i was
growing up in hong kong but 7-11
was called 7-eleven because it was open
from seven o'clock till 11
p.m right yeah and it was only later
that 7-11 became this 24-hour
sort of supermarket or or convenience
store
and now today you know 20-30 years later
we live in a 24-7
uh capitalist cycle where you know day
and night
um we're sort of fueling the economy and
of course you can see this from space
but wouldn't it be really wonderful and
wouldn't we save so much tremendous
energy
if we were able to turn out the lights
so that we would be able to have
you know our night skies again and that
birds could migrate again
and insects would be able to sort of you
know move with the state of the moon
and and sort of the inspiration for this
you know as a final digression
is because i remember and the story that
i told in the article is the fact that
you know in the 1990s
there was a power outage in los angeles
and all these people started calling the
griffith observatory freaking out
because they didn't know what that
magnificent orb like
the cloud was in the sky and they
started fielding all these calls and the
reason was because these people had
never seen the milky way
right you know and we live in the state
right now where
we we've forgotten what it means to be
humbled by the state of the universe
we've forgotten what it means to be
small to scale ourselves against the the
vastness of the universe and how
beautiful that is and how that can
really reposition uh our place in the
world so
those are just a couple of ideas in
terms of a path forward
my version of that story is i used to
work with project exploration in chicago
which was
an outreach organization that worked
with disadvantaged
children uh to get them interested in
science and their primary way
was to get them to use dinosaurs which
is like the second most exciting thing
after the universe right
so they would yeah the you know the ones
who uh were accepted in the program
would go on train trips to you know
montana to a real dinosaur fossil site
and dig them up and you would think that
would be you know the most amazing thing
that ever happened to these kids but in
fact
what really impressed them is that they
could see the stars
yes because they grew up in chicago and
had never seen stars before forget about
the milky way you know the idea of like
their dots of light in the sky
was a life-changing experience yeah that
and that is so profoundly beautiful and
like that is uh
very similar to i mean i was inspired by
that because i did meet a friend when i
lived in new york and uh
he had said to me as an adult he had
never seen the stars
and and there's something really
beautiful about that which does bring us
full circle
back to that very beginning of galileo
just being able to look up into the sky
and and the numinous you know it's
incredibly inspiring
so food for thought whether or not we're
going to pay attention to where the food
comes from i think zayatong thanks so
much for being on the windscape podcast
as i said to you i knew it would be a
joy it really was
[Music]
you